pourrait-on créer un parfum qui sont
tirées parfaitement vous certains
essayent au japon il existe des parfums
qui sentent l'odeur des cheveux de qui
après une journée de travail ou de
culotte après une séance de sport
et vu la tête de cet outil buzz ça a pas
l'air incroyable la question que je me
suis posée c'est qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans la tête du chimiste qui a
fait ça comme on l'a fait pour trouver
les ingrédients c'est quoi les molécules
dans la culotte d'une fille la question
de bizarre mais les scientifiques
quelles molécules nous fait sentir
mauvais qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour
produire la pire odeur du monde et au
fond qu'est-ce qui fait qu'une simple
molécule cuisse est aussi repousse ans
on répond à tout ça enfilez vos blouses
aujourd'hui c'est chimie quels sont les
molécules de l'odeur humaine
à la naissance les humains ne puis pas
ils sentent même plutôt bons une odeur
de neuf de biscuits ou les shows et
selon une étude ça rendrait accroc les
mamans y prend la tête de leur bébé
toute la journée une mécanique utile en
termes d'évolution puisque dans ces
conditions la maman singes aura moins
tendance à abandonner son petit claude
heures par contre n'est pas à proprement
parler émises par le bébé mais par la
sir qui l'entourent quand il est dans le
ventre de sa mère elle disparaît
complètement
quelques jours après la naissance c'est
en vieillissant que vous allez peu à peu
développé votre véritable odeur humaine
qui en réalité ne l'est pas vraiment le
main naturellement ne put pas votre
sueur ce n'est que de l'eau et quelques
acides aminés
le problème c'est les milliards de
bactéries qui vont s'en nourrir les
digérer je fous faire caca dessus
ouais sentir la sueur c'est être le taux
à l'aide publique et bactéries sur votre
peau si les humains ont d odeur de sueur
différentes c'est parce que leur pack
terry leçon certains vont produire une
odeur de vinaigre d'oignons de chèvre ou
des pis une légende
selon votre type de peau ventre
environnement vous aurez un cocktail
bactérien unique votre odeur signature
ce qui est fou c'est que ce qui exhale
de votre sueur peut changer en quelques
minutes
prenez le stress vous puez quand vous
stressé c'est parce que le cortisol
l'hormone du stress va vous faire suer
la grèce ça la grèce les bactéries adore
s'en faut un festin cette sueur
graisseuses elle est générée par les
glandes sud
ripart apocrines des glandes qu'on ne
retrouve qu'à des endroits précis du
corps et celle pubis anus mamelon elle
ne s'active qu'à l'adolescence c'est
pour ça que les enfants ne sont pas
comme les adultes
ces glandes sudoripares voit aussi
émettre et phéromone malheureusement
vous n'arrivez pas à les sentir
volkan première nasal qui est censé
s'occuper de la perception des
phéromones chez les animaux dans votre
nez il est désactivé un chien s'est
immédiatement si vous avez peur vous
avez pas mais quand même certaines
personnes ont une odeur perceptible par
exemple l'androstènedione l'odeur
masculine musqué et boisé excitante qui
pour certains sans lui rien à cause d'un
gène défectueux
si vous n'aimez pas l'odeur des garçons
voilà la cause en parlant de gênes 2 %
de la population européenne n'a aucune
odeur de sueur lors gênes a baissé ses
11 est un terreau intégré qui ne leur
fait suer que de l'eau et donc pas rien
pour nourrir les bactéries mais balade
on ou sur d'autres zones odorantes de
votre corps si vous sentez de la bouche
le matin c'est parce que les bactéries
dans votre bouche se sont attaqués à
quelques morceaux de nourriture qui sont
restés pendant la nuit ce qui produit de
la cada verrines la même substance que
les cadavres
quand on vous dit que votre haleine sans
la mort et les poubelles c'est
totalement vrai sur vos pieds les
bactéries produisent de l'acide
isobel eric qu'on trouve dans le fromage
d'où l'odeur mais aussi dans l'uriné de
chat donc vos panard pour hisser au
temps du cheddar que de la vieille
litière pas fraîche ceci dit encore une
fois à cause d'un gène défaillant
l'odeur du pied peut être agréable pour
certains ce qu' une des causes du style
schisme des pieds en parlant d'odeurs
agréable vous êtes vous déjà demandé
pourquoi vous aimez celle de vos prout
on pourrait s'attendre à des gaz idmont
mais pas du tout pour vous dire il ya
même des études scientifiques pour
déterminer la composition des prout et
ça devait être une expérience bizarre
les flatulences ont été quantitativement
collectées via tube rectal inséré dans
ces sujets ayant à gérer des haricots
afin d'accroître les émissions la
concentration en gaz a été corrélée à
l'intensification de l'odeur contrôlé
par deux
c'est la science ma bonne dame résultats
sulfure d'hydrogène méthane et violent
et sulfure de diméthyle qui sont tous
les trois des poisons quelques grammes
suffisent à vous tuer
on a même calculé le nombre de prout
nécessaires à une dose létale 350 va
falloir en manger beaucoup des haricots
pour certains malheureusement une
mauvaise odeur i synonyme de maladie le
diabète sans la pomme la typhoïde le
pain frais et l'atr imite si la mine riz
le poisson pourrit la vie et ceci peut
générer des odeurs puisque vos oméga-6
ne se métabolise plus correctement et
vous produisez du 2 nominale l'odeur des
concombres et de votre papilles comment
créer la pire odeur du monde en 1989 une
molécule a fait l'objet d'une des pires
expériences de l'histoire la sphère du
thillot acétone de friedberg en
allemagne du gaz s'est échappé du
laboratoire et s'est répandu dans toute
la ville annick nausées évanouissement
ses pattes le gars soit toxique
c'est la pire odeur du monde le tiercé
tonnes à garder ce titre jusqu'en 1998
à cette date le ministère de la défense
des états unis a engagé une chercheuse
afin de produire une bombe puante
militaire ça a marché
et elle produirait une odeur similaire à
ce que tu peux imaginer être le
toilettes du film trainspotting
malheureusement ce n'est pas une
molécule mais un cocktail de molécules
qu'est ce qu'elles ont en commun pour
être aussi universellement désagréable
le principal point commun à presque
toutes les molécules polluantes se
trouve dans le tableau périodique
elle possède tout soit des composés
azotés oxygénée soit du soufre soit du
sélénium
ces atomes vous le voyez sont toutes
dans la même colonne du tableau les lois
même de la physique et de la chimie les
ondes destiné à sentir mauvais alors
soyons fous créons une molécule
d'abominations si puantes qu'elle vous
ferez instantanément tomber dans les
pommes
il nous faudrait du carbone pour le côté
essence brûlé un peu de soufre ou de
sélénium pour l'odeur d'oeuf pourri le
tout bien et aller avec plein
d'hydrogène pour que ça soit le plus
volatile possible cette substance existe
juste celeno phénol et ça donne selon la
science l'odeur de sim ou fait virer
dans des pneus pourquoi une molécule
sent mauvais on entend souvent dire que
l'homme est la risée du monde animal en
matière d'eau doha c'est pas tout à fait
vrai va dépendre des molécules par
exemple nous sentons qu'il ya mieux la
vanille qu'un chien quelques petits
microgrammes par mètre cube suffisent
qui veut dire que deux pétroliers rempli
de baline serait suffisant pour donner
cette odeur délicieuse à la terre
entière mais commence en nous eh bien je
vais vous étonner et on ne sait pas
quand une molécule entre dans votre nez
on sait qu'elle va se lier un récepteurs
olfactifs envoyer des signaux
électriques à votre cerveau qui va
associer l'odeur à une image une
sensation un souvenir mais ça se passe
comment au niveau des récepteurs
on pensait à une époque que les
récepteurs et les molécules fonctionner
un peu comme une clé inné serrure on
aurait eu plein de capteurs spécialisés
ayant parfaitement la forme de la
molécule cette explication a un problème
ça voudrait dire que pour chaque odeur
de l'univers nous aurions dans notre adn
un récepteur déjà parfaitement codé pour
l'accueillir
et ça serait précis par exemple entre
l'odeur de la menthe ou celle de l'aneth
elle a beau être différente c'est
quasiment la même molécule la même forme
sauf que la boule jaune passe en dessous
imaginez donc l'infinité des
possibilités dans les quelques
centimètres carrés de votre nez voilà
pourquoi la science a trouvé une autre
explication
l'idée est que chaque molécule peut être
vu comme plein d'à tomates hachées par
des ressorts qui vibre une vibration
quantique c'est cette vibration qui
serait en fait intercepter par votre nez
et ils en ont la preuve ils ont pris une
molécule de cyclos ppd cannon qui a une
odeur très très musclé et très tenace
ils ont remplacé tous les atomes
d'hydrogène par son cousin plus lourd le
deutérium c'est de l'hydrogène avec
juste un neutron en plus on a donc la
même forme
la même molécule mais plus la même
vibration quantique et devinez quoi
l'odeur à changer la mauvaise odeur et
donc quantique mais surtout
sociologique parce que depuis tout à
l'heure on parle de mauvaises odeurs
mais ça reste subjectif
les auteurs ne sont pas repoussante par
nature on pourrait se dire que l'odeur
de cadavres n'aurait pu mieux pour nous
protéger pour nous empêcher d'en manger
mais c'est loin d'être vrai le benzène
la délicieuse odeur des stations essence
basse et du gaz toxiques
l'arsenic ça sent l'ail ben c'est un
truc qu'on mangeait l'arsenic je vous
conseille pas trop mon contraire un truc
qui sent mauvais peut parfois être beau
le vomi et le parmesan sentent
exactement la même chose mais taisant
sur une pizza chaude prenez une grande
inspiration et dites vous que c'est du
vomi vous allez voir et c'est radical
pareil pour l'odeur métalliques des
pièces en fait c'est la même odeur qu'un
champignon
oui beaucoup de mauvaises odeurs peuvent
être associés à quelque chose d'agréable
de choses que vous adorez manger tout ça
bah ça va dépendre du contexte de votre
culture aussi le durian ça sent le
durian si vous avez grandi avec ça vous
associez ça une odeur de fruits sinon
bah comme ces européens
vous trouvez que ça sent l'hogneau
pourri culture qui s'immisce jusque dans
le bébé en gestation
une mère fumeuse transmettra son enfant
l'amour pour l'odeur de la cigarette
associé au réconfort voilà qui j'espère
vous permettra de relativiser quand
quelque chose plus c'est pas la mort
c'est juste des molécules qui activent
des récepteurs quantique dans votre nez
une parfaite excuse si vous lâchez un
prout dit man commentaire quelle est la
pire odeurs selon vous
celle que vous détestez s'il ya des
trucs scientifique admire pas gelé
j'ajouterai en commentaire merci à ma
tarte à ce cahier à tous les moteurs
pour le raid c'était une grosse vidéo
allez les amis tiens
[Musique]